foreign
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
in this session we will be learning
about how to become a successful Java
developer in the year 2023 but before we
begin I'd like to tell you guys that we
have daily updates on multiple
Technologies so if you're a tech geek in
a continuous hunt for latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply learn now without further Ado
let's get started the idea of computer
programming began in the year 1948 many
languages were developed in a quest to
become better than their predecessors
out of thousands one stood Valiant
facing the test of time to prove it's
the best of all worlds you're right we
are talking about the Java programming
language Java was introduced in the
early 1995s due to its exceptional
features Java managed to build many
operating systems application software
and many more than 35 percent of
developers use Java worldwide Java has
one of the biggest programming
communities resources and online
repositories the minimum salary of a
Java developer in the United States of
America is about two hundred thousand
dollars per annum and in India the
minimum salary of a Java developer is
around 10 to 15 lakhs per annum based on
your experience
if you are one of those aspiring Java
developers came to know the perfect way
that explains how to become a successful
Java developer in 2023 then you are at
the right place you're watching simply
learn and if these are the types of
videos you'd like to watch then hit that
subscribe button and the bell icon to be
notified without further Ado here's how
to become a successful Java developer in
the year 2023 if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
first we begin with the core Java
fundamentals what's better to learn Java
than getting started to code core Java
covers the Java fundamentals like Java
variables data types in Java conditional
statements in Java looping statements in
Java object-oriented programming
paradigms in Java and Java Collections
learning core Java fundamentals will be
a strong foundation for becoming a
successful Java developer you can get
started with core Java tutorial link to
this video proceeding ahead we need to
get started with Advanced Java Advanced
Java programming covers real-time
programming paradigms like error
handling exception handling Java
servlets Java API programming Java
database connection that is the jdbc
Java Enterprise programming which is
Java ee Java Lambda functions junit
testing and much more to clarify
Advanced Java is the most important part
of becoming a Java developer as the
corporate mainly works in the advanced
Java segment of java once you're strong
with the core Java and advanced Java
fundamentals you should start building
your own Java projects there are a wide
variety of java projects you can build
you can get started with core Java
projects to help you lay a stronger
foundation in learning how to work with
Java IDs and build and maintain an
actual project simply learn has code
Java project ideas and complete core
Java project building tutorial to guide
you not just that we also have Java API
programming tutorial Java jdbc
programming along with the top 10
Advanced Java project ideas and a fully
fledged Advanced Java project tutorial
that will help you the actual
programming stage is when you encounter
errors and compile time issues I want
you to know that the help is just around
the corner sign up and join some biggest
and most popular Java communities the
online programming communities will have
top programmers and experts who have
tried and tested solution to multiple
problems including yours communicating
your problems will help you learn new
things and build a better team player
profile that companies are accustomed to
and looking to hire
simply learn has a dedicated team and
Java programming community and multiple
social media platforms like Telegram and
the link to it is in the description box
below proceeding further practice to
enhance your skills and participate in
online boot camps by now you must be the
master of all critical Java Concepts
despite being a programmer comfortable
in Java testing your skills and learning
where you stand makes you a complete
programmer next you can try practicing
your programming skills and answer some
online brain tasting questions many
websites host competitive programming
events based on Java and that can be
resourceful to test your programming
caliber these questions will be prepared
by real-time industry experts and hiring
managers these technical questions will
test your skills to the Limit and
determine how strong are your algorithm
skills
codequest by simply loan has multiple
questions that can help you analyze the
algorithms and devise a perfect solution
finally we must build a resume matching
the recruiter's requirement every
recruiter has a specific requirement
before you apply for a certain job role
I'd recommend you go through the job
description that explains the
requirements in detail ensure you have
all the skills listed and design your
resume in a realistic way that explains
your skill set and experience the
important point is to try to put your
skills and experience aligned to the
recruiter's requirement not just these
let's say you walk into an interview
with a decent portfolio of projects that
align with your recruiting firm explain
to your hiring manager about your
portfolio and say I am working on a
similar project and I'd like to learn
more and add a few inputs from my end
now who would say no to that say simply
learn has a wide spectrum of Open Source
Java projects that can help you learn
the fundamentals of project building
using Java they can also help you build
and manage a dominant Java portfolio
certifications help you get one step
closer to your dream carrier so what are
you waiting for head straight to the
simply learn website to upskill and get
ahead please do let us know if we need
to include any important pointers and we
call it afrap we have come to an end of
the session on how to become a
successful Java developer in 2023 in
conclusion the future of java looks
promising it possesses the caliber to
reshape all the technology sectors and
there is simply no stopping it thank you
for being here and watch out for more
videos from us and until then keep
learning and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here